kelly goulding joins us now only on cbs
morning we welcome you ellie because i
love the lyrics where it says keep it
cool on me don't be cruel of me because
we know you've done it before yeah now
my understanding is this song is about
women who keep going back to the same
guy even though they know that he's a
jerk that's exactly it yeah do you have
an inspiration for the song you just
thought you know this could be good to
write i had some people in mind for that
song no i actually wrote that song about
six years ago
um but i mean it stood the test of time
because
does because there's always someone
who's acting in a jerky way exactly but
this is the thing about your new music
that's coming out you started recording
it during the pandemic did it affect the
kind of music that you wanted to release
did it affect your process yeah the last
album was very much more uh about myself
and much more introspective and um
talking about the process of i don't
know becoming a woman after
uh touring for my entire 20s and then i
and then yeah i started writing about um
coming off the back of that but then to
be honest nobody when i got in the
studio and we could actually get back in
the studio for the first time um after
lockdown um nobody wanted to write
anything but like upbeat dance no
ballads no balance nobody was in the
mood for it so um you know we we love
house music and in the in the uk um
actually i think everyone loves it now
yeah like beyonce has taken yes it's all
different too um but yes so so i think
people just wanted to um
maybe it was like an escapism thing but
like um yeah so it was so the next album
is very upbeat and very dance and big
sean's on this one too which is
interesting to hear your two voices
together yeah he he sampled me a long
time ago on on an album i think it was
like 10 years ago now god uh but um but
we always said that we we would do
something proper together and together
the other big shift in your life uh last
year is you became a mother baby arthur
yeah we can call you arthur's mom
how does that sound to you arthur and
also yeah ello i've got a 15 month old
who's starting to dance you know gets
wide there's a little side to side yeah
he does actually he kind of he walks
along you know that kind of like drunken
walk that they do when they start
walking and he kind of does this loves
classical music that you know those
books where you can press the button and
it plays music he loves those pressing
it non-stop uh but no it's been it's
been an incredible uh you know 16 months
with him um completely wild completely
blown my mind in so many ways how does
being a mother change your perspective
um not just on the world but also as an
artist oh wow well i i mean pretty much
in every single way like i i would have
to say that motherhood has has affected
me in pretty much every way conceivable
as an artist and a person um i don't
know if it's changed my music
all i know is that i just wanna i want
him to think i'm cool
as much as we want to please our kids we
also want our kids to be we want to be
proud of them as well yeah you know
you've talked also very candidly about
your your journey with mental health and
anxiety how does it manifest itself to
for you and what do you do about it
yeah i i i think i just i don't know if
you guys have the same but you just get
this
uh new kind of fear like everything
becomes a little bit scarier and i think
about things a lot more you know even
flying now i i
yeah i get i've got like a fear of
flying now since i had arthur um but
yeah it did kind of bring on this this
anxious time for me i think the biggest
uh remedy was getting in the studio and
writing and singing actually because um
i always tell people who especially fans
who message me and anxiety is really on
the rise and i get um so many tweets um
saying you know i'm really anxious you
know i wake up you know anxious and i
can't breathe and so i actually talk a
lot about breathing and singing is such
a good thing for that actually because
it's so much breath control and so much
about you know the anxiety is from like
you know taking these shallow breaths
because you're kind of um tense um so so
i always tell people to take a breath
can you talk about flying and being
anxious but you went to the ukraine i
was going to say all the more remarkable
yeah i did um well that's so so um that
was like a very long train journey
actually was that a little scary for you
it was scary i i i i got a request um to
sing there actually um and and also
speak a little bit um about climate
because i work for the um ep so i i talk
a lot about my climate activism um and
uh
yeah it was it was like a daunting
prospect but then
i figured that people are still
living that every single day of their
lives and their children are living that
every day yeah um so i took a train into
kiev um i did a little uh talk it was
like a i was invited by the first lady
it was like a first lady forum um and uh
and then and then i got to sing um like
a local song so they're singing a lot at
the moment um it's like a song of
resistance so it was it was um scary but
you know people are there's still a war
going on well listen we appreciate your
music but more importantly we love what
you do outside of the studio ellie
golden thank you so much thank you we'll
be right back congrats